there's a lot of news to get to Major
movement in the 2024 presidential race a
Democrat power grab to destroy the
Supreme Court Mitt Romney's views on hot
dogs we will get to all of it but first
a major announcement
I teased this yesterday
I'm prepared to give you the full story
if you're driving I suggest you pull
over if you were standing up you might
want to sit down
six years after its initial publication
my best-selling blank book reasons to
vote for Democrats a comprehensive guide
has been translated into Hungarian
the Hungarian Edition is titled
mierch is
the book will be available in bookstores
throughout Hungary as early as next
Tuesday
it is available right now for pre-order
at Libre
libri.hu it is sadly not available on
Amazon because Amazon does not operate
in the nation of Hungary
very excited for this launch by the way
this is not if you're watching right now
instead of listening this is not the
real book uh the book hasn't hit
bookstores yet so I had my producers
tape the cover around another book and
they did an absolutely terrible job so
the real book will look much better than
this I'm very excited about this launch
though I'm so excited that I'm gonna go
to Hungary
I'm gonna go to Hungary for for a
full-on book tour next week to promote
my blank book in its Hungarian
translation and then at the end of the
week I'm going to give a speech at the
Matthias corvinus kolegium Fest that'll
be next Friday if you're in or around
Budapest I hope to see you there in the
three days between the publication of
miyar is
my speech I hope that my national best
seller becomes an international
bestseller I'm I'm relying on you to
make that happen because six years on I
am confident that this book's message
resonates now more than ever not just in
our own country but throughout the
entire world
I'm Michael Knowles this the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show this episode is
brought to you by good ranchers yet a
great meet at a secure price my favorite
meat in the world 30 bucks off your
order with my code Knowles go to
goodranchers.com use code Knowles today
Mitt Romney has eaten a hot dog
almost as breaking news as the Hungarian
translation in my blank book we will get
to the meaning behind Mitt Romney's
viral hot dog video really important
stuff this Friday you don't want to miss
this kind of news first though I guess
we've got to slog through some minor
details about the 2024 presidential race
namely there's a new number two
candidate
now this doesn't mean that DeSantis is
no longer number two it means that he's
now sharing the number two spot with
another candidate this according to
Kaplan poll the vague ramaswamy the Rama
Swami mommies just pushing their
candidate up from where did he start
fifth or sixth place or something he was
down at almost zero percent now
according to this Kaplan survey he is
tied with Ron DeSantis for second place
according to this survey they're both
tied at 12 points
and they're well behind president Trump
who is at 48 percent
what does this mean it's still Silly
Season it's a national poll it it
doesn't mean a whole lot in terms of
what's going to happen in Iowa New
Hampshire South Carolina Florida it does
mean though
that
if you want to move in this race you got
to stop playing it safe the vague is the
only candidate in the whole race from
Trump to DeSantis to Pence to Chris
Christie to ASA Hutchinson Vivek is the
only one to Nikki Haley to Tim Scott
there are other people in the race too
the vake is the only one who is mixing
it up and not playing it safe and
putting himself in Risk on the campaign
Trail in positions that he's taking in
campaign stunts that he's pulling and
it's paying off he's the only candidate
who's moving
and even if it's just one poll even if
it just kind of looks like he's tied
nationally with DeSantis that kind of
momentum that kind of movement is a
really big deal so yes it's early on but
if he's getting this kind of positive
movement early on where's he going to be
in two months three months four months
this should be a warning sign to one
candidate in particular Ron DeSantis
if you want to have a shot at the big
job you've got to stop playing it safe
this is not a message to Trump trump
doesn't need to stop playing it safe
because he's so far ahead of all the
other candidates
so for trump it makes sense to just not
show up to the Iowa Town Halls not show
up too much on the campaign Trail not
commit to doing the Republican debates
makes total sense for him
if DeSantis keeps playing it really safe
and smart and cautious and he's got all
the best consultants and he's got he's
hearing all the best strategy advice on
here's you got to bide your time he's
going to wind up like Ted Cruz he's
going to be a really good candidate who
says many of the right things whose
scientifically precise about his
campaign down to the minutest detail and
he's going to come in number two maybe
maybe not even number two a a major it's
like I've been trying to shake the
DeSantis campaign by the shoulders here
gotta mix it up guys or or you're not
gonna have a shot now when I try to talk
to other friends and family I
have to rely on pure talk right now go
to puretalk.com Knowles you know a
company is looking out for you when they
upgrade your service and they don't even
charge you for it well that's what Pure
Talk has done for new and current Pure
Talk customers pure talk just added data
to every plan and included a mobile
hotspot
with no price increase whatsoever if
you've considered pure talk before but
haven't made the switch take a look
again for just twenty dollars a month
you will get unlimited talk text and now
50 more 5G data plus their new mobile
hotspot this is one of the many reasons
I love Pure Talk they're veteran owned
and only hire the best customer service
team located right here in the great us
of a most families are saving almost a
thousand bucks a year thousand bucks a
year imagine what you could do with that
while enjoying the most Dependable 5G
Network in America remember you vote
with how you spend your money so stop
supporting woke wireless companies that
don't support you go to puretalk.com
Knowles save an additional fifty five
zero percent off your first month
because they actually value you that is
puretalk.com
Wireless for Americans buy Americans
by the way there's another very serious
candidate waiting in the wings not even
declared yet that candidate would be
Glenn young remember Glenn younken
there have been two very very impressive
governors in the last couple of years
Ron DeSantis of course in Florida
Glenn young in Virginia
Glenn youngin wins his race in Virginia
which is a blue Commonwealth
by running well initially he tries to
run on just cutting taxes
and all that business Country Club kind
of Republican stuff and he was going
nowhere and then
young can leaned into more of the
cultural issues
critical race theory in schools
bathrooms in schools daily wire broke a
story
on that ladder issue and that story and
that issue may have thrown the race to
Glenn yankin
there and
inside every Governor is a president
just waiting to come out so Jenkins
looking at it he's reportedly meeting
with some donors in fact he's meeting
with Trump's former Commerce Secretary
Wilbur Ross hosting a meet and greet for
Glenn yankin Glenn yankin has no
shortage of wealthy friends he was the
co-ceo of the Carlisle group I think
it's the largest private Equity Fund in
the world they they had this meet and
greet at Wilbur Ross's Southampton or
they're having the meet and greet at
Wilbur Ross's Southampton home and what
is youngin doing here is he declaring no
is he starting a Super PAC no but
he reportedly sent word to Trump
that he's only making these moves so
that he can be in the discussion and in
contention for VP
now again this is all just according to
reports from the New York Post and some
other places now but assuming those
reports are right
this is a smart move for youngin because
if you're Glenn youngin you're thinking
okay in many ways I'm comparable to Ron
DeSantis Rhonda santis is more
conservative than I am Rhonda Santos is
more effective than I am but Florida is
also more conservative than Virginia is
so given our relative States okay I'm
doing okay but but DeSantis is being
just ground up in the Donald Trump meat
grinder as would any candidate and so I
want to put myself in a position where I
could be the president especially as
Donald Trump's facing three indictments
he's probably going to face 30 more by
the time the election comes around so I
want to put myself in that position but
if I want to put myself in that position
without also getting ground up by the
Trump campaign machine then I need to
directly coordinate with Trump and say
hey bro I'm not threatening you
I'm not gonna run if you're running
as much out of self-interest as out of
any kind of loyalty don't worry I'm on
your side in fact I want to help you in
fact I want to be your vice president
that's a smart way to play this
and it's something that
the other candidates I think did not
sufficiently take into account in this
primary race you can see Vivek is
playing pretty nicely with Trump he's
reserving more of his criticism for the
number two candidate Ron DeSantis and it
seems to have benefited him in the polls
the Trump campaign
is
brutal it is brutal it will especially
if their candidates way way up right now
and the candidate is running effectively
as an incumbent they're going to chew
people up so Glenn young and very smart
says he only wants to be BP of course he
has no designs on being president this
cycle but it's a long ways to the
election and there are a lot of
indictments coming down the pike we
could end up in a situation very
plausibly end up in a situation in 2024
where the two candidates for the major
parties are neither Biden nor Trump so
what is what is Young doing to help
himself in Virginia well he just had his
education department finalize a new rule
requiring all public schools to get
parental permission before cooperating
with students who want to
[Music]
now DeSantis in Florida he's going
further than Glenn Young and the
political circumstances in Florida allow
him to do that so again I am I am
grading a little bit on a curve here but
DeSantis is playing great with what he's
got available to him DeSantis just
ordered his State Board of
administration to investigate the assets
of Kaiser Bush that that Florida has
invested in
so uh they say this is DeSantis
a sales of a b inbev products and for
those of you who are unaware a b inbev
is the official corporate name of the
company much better known as Tizer Bush
and sales of a b inbev products within
the U.S continue to precipitously
decline reports are now merging that
large American Mainstays like Costco
will be pulling Bud Light from the
shelves clearly the board's
mismanagement as well as its failure to
remediate the problem and repair its
relationship with millions of
disaffected American customers has led
to this impasse and will continue to
financially harm the SBA and other
shareholders so he's really smart about
what he's saying here he's not just
saying we need to punish
Professor Bush because Bud Light went
woke
he's saying well are Shucks or sharks
Kaiser Bush went woke and now the stock
price is collapsing and the profits are
collapsing
and so it's my responsibility as someone
with the fiduciary interest of
Floridians you know on my shoulders
we've got we've got to pull out
we've got to stop supporting just to
protect ourselves
now the effect of this of course is
going to be the same and it's going to
be the same knock that the libs and the
squishes make especially the squishes
make on Ron DeSantis which is he's
wielding the government
to punish the people who he thinks are
doing bad things
but he's not he's such a hypocrite he's
not wielding the government to punish
the people who are doing good things
that's true that's right it's called
politics
it's called statecraft
it's called conserving anything at all
right
you should not treat good and bad as the
same
you should not treat true and false as
the same you should not treat beautiful
and ugly is the same they're different
and we need to use our judgment and our
prudence and our wisdom in statecraft to
discern between the two because if you
treat them the same you're going to get
a decaying degrading country and
ultimately you're going to get a very
bad country that thrives or decays
unfalsehood and that lives amid ugliness
really good stuff from
DeSantis it's bold it's in the right
direction
strongly strongly encourage other
Republicans to follow suit speaking of
power plays Maisie hirono
one of the
more frequently marked members of the
United States Senate
Maisie is a Democrat senator
she is insisting that if the Supreme
Court
does not adopt
the code of ethics that she wants it to
adopt
then she and her fellow senators are
going to force one on the Supreme Court
first of all let's understand that the
United States Supreme Court does not
have a code of ethic the kind of code of
ethics that applies to all other federal
judges so the highest court in the land
should set a standard should set the
highest standard they do not and so this
is a bill that would do that and what
will it do it will establish a procedure
for investigating ethical violations
it'll make much clearer recusal
requirements and the third is to give
the court time to adopt the code of
ethics and if they do not then one will
be
provided to them
Senator how exactly do you plan to then
enforce those guidelines
the guidelines we've done through the a
commission that is established by the
judicial conference and so that there
are judicial conference procedures for
the investigating these kinds of things
good on the CNN guy good on the CNN guy
for asking the obvious question here
What Maisie hirono is suggesting sounds
kind of nice if you don't know anything
about politics and haven't thought about
this issue for more than two seconds
because it's it's crazy that the Supreme
Court doesn't have a code of ethics now
first of all the Supreme Court obviously
has
quite a code of ethics it's not written
down on a sheet of paper necessarily but
the Supreme Court has all sorts of
traditions and ethical standards that it
abides by and they're very very high
but it doesn't have a written down
formal code of ethics that's true
why might that be
because it's the highest court in the
land and the the CNN guy raises this
question he says well
who's going to hold them accountable to
the code of ethics and Maisie hirono's
answer is very dangerous here and this
whole Movement by the Senate Democrats
to hold the Supreme Court to a code of
ethics that is just jargony euphemistic
gobbledygook to
to allow for a senate takeover of the
Supreme Court to allow for the Takeover
of one branch of government by another
branch of government because her answer
is who's going to hold them to it we
will
we are going to decide what cases the
judges are allowed to operate the the
judges are allowed to participate in
and when we say that what do we mean we
mean we're going to make Clarence Thomas
recuse himself we're going to make Amy
Barrett recuse herself we're going to
make the leader we're going to make the
conservatives recuse themselves and
we're going to hold them accountable
that's not how the Constitution works
that's not how the branches of
government work this is
something that the Senate has no right
to do and if the Senate were able to
steal this kind of a power it would be
I I say without exaggeration probably
the biggest threat to our system of
government in at least half a century
maybe more
now one threat to your happiness
is if you don't have good meat for
dinner that's why you got to check out
good ranchers right now go to
goodranchors.com use promo code Knowles
you know that I love anything made with
top of the line quality I am a simple
man I am easily Satisfied by the very
best when it comes to me that is good
ranchers period I have good ranchers
every two or three days now I think and
probably the only reason I don't have it
more is because I'm on the road a lot
the other night we had beautiful good
ranchers filet mignon and ribeye and my
only complaint about the dinner was that
my little one-year-old baby was gobbling
up the rib eye faster than I was
you've got to check out good ranchers
okay the the one thing that you might
say has been missing from good ranchers
steak is great the Burger's unbelievable
the chicken's great you might say Well
they're missing pork until now good
ranchers just launched their Prime pork
100 American pork that is Steakhouse
quality new pork box comes with bone-in
and boneless pork chops sausage smoked
brats more right now you get 30 bucks
off with my code Knolls
goodranchers.com they got everything the
prime beef the prime pork the better
than organic chicken it's just the
greatest goodranchers.com use code
Knolls
goodranchers.com use code Nails get 30
bucks off any box go to ranchers.com
American Meat delivered my favorite
comment yesterday is from Michael
biesental four to four two five nine who
says Mars retailer green must have been
spending too much time with Michael's
producers to have found such obscene
material it's so true This Crew these
producers we're gonna call them the
weird sex stuff team over here that's
why I would say it's a full third of my
show many days not today actually
because today we're talking about
important things like the Hungarian
translation of my blank book and the
2024 presidential race and Mitt Romney
eating a hot dog I guess that's the most
scintillating thing of the day which
which we will get to but I don't want to
move on too quickly from the Supreme
Court
the Supreme Court
has to be able
to to rule itself
the Supreme Court has to have a lot of
authority just as the Supreme Court
doesn't go in and totally dominate the
U.S Senate so too the uh Senate can't go
in and totally dominate the Supreme
Court we have a system of checks and
balances and a separation of powers for
a reason the reason that we have that is
to try to stop the natural decay of the
cycle of regimes and this is a problem
that has been recognized since the old
ancient Greeks people like polybius the
Greek historian of of the Romans who
observed
that uh
regimes naturally Decay so if you have a
monarchy it's naturally going to Decay
into something else if you have an
oligarchy it's natural and aristocracy
it's naturally going to Decay into
something else if you have a democracy
something else and it you're going to be
stuck in the cycle forever and ever and
ever and so the classical conception of
a mixed regime Endeavors to
stop or at the very least slow down that
that decay in cycle of regimes and the
American founding fathers tried to do a
similar thing when they established the
government
with an executive and A legislature and
a Judiciary that were separated and had
checks and balances on one another the
point of that was to to give us a more
stable regime and what they were trying
to do you see in the writings of Saint
Thomas Aquinas you see in the writings
of a lot of great Statesmen and a lot of
great thinkers throughout history
they're saying okay if we have
not just a monarchy or an aristocracy or
a democracy but if we have elements of
all of those things in the United States
the executive is
kind of like a monarchy it's got
elements and aspects of a monarchy the
Senate as well as other elements of our
constitution
they're kind of like an aristocracy and
obviously the representation of the
people is
significantly like a democracy well if
you have them all at once
maybe you can slow down that decay and
we have been just trying we've been dead
set ever since on destroying that system
the directional election of centers
would be would be one of the things that
upends the regime the Senate trying to
dominate the Supreme Court same thing
they want to do it though because they
have the the libs have no particular
care for the stability of our regime in
fact they don't really like the way our
regime was set up to begin with and they
want to make it uh
much more conducive to their exercise of
power even if it destabilizes the whole
country now we've got to get to Mitt
Romney eating a hot dog
really important stuff
speaking of the Senate Mitt Romney
posted this video a few days ago it has
gone viral
well as you all know today is National
Hot Dog Day and perhaps you also know
that hot dog is my favorite meat I love
hot dogs I love them in buns I love them
outside of buns I love them with baked
beans I just like hot dogs it's the best
you know meat there is without question
so to all of you who like me are
celebrating a national hat Hot Dog Day
uh congratulations to you and may there
be many many more hot dogs served in our
wonderful land
did you catch it if you were listening
you didn't catch it I know he sounds a
little stilted it's it has a little bit
the aspect of how do you do fellow
humans he's wearing a hat that's got a
hot dog on it he's walking around with
the hot dog it's a little awkward but
kind of charming and endearing actually
by the standard of Mitt Romney did you
catch the problem though there's always
something with this guy
and here's the problem
ketchup
he's got ketchup on the hot dog
of course he does of course Mitt Romney
puts ketchup on that I don't want to
read
too much into Mitt Romney's hot dog
tells you a lot about his politics
though
no person over the age of 18. really no
person over the age of 14 or 15 should
ever put ketchup on a hot dog it is
sugary sweet it destroys the delicious
taste and flavor and complexities of the
hot dog a hot dog is meant to be enjoyed
with
chopped onions or relish I'm not a big
relish guy but some people like it
sauerkraut I I need sauerkraut on a hot
dog mustard but not ketchup ketchup is
for little children
and
this reflects Mitt Romney's politics
Mitt Romney's politics are for little
children Mitt Romney's politics are for
for people who don't want to play in the
big leagues
Mitt Romney's politics are
so
doe-wide naive
innocent or perhaps
cynical Mitt Romney is the kind of
Republican
who
either always allows himself to get
duped or concedes from the very
beginning what made your political fight
has Mitt Romney ever won for the
conservatives
none
he invented Obamacare that was
unfortunate he
was run rough shot over in the race
against Obama
and he spent the last seven or eight
years attacking Republicans consistently
in undermining conservative priorities
maybe that's because he really believes
what he says and I give him the benefit
of the doubt maybe when he says we just
need to meet in the middle and be really
conciliatorian come on work across the
aisle or maybe it's because he just
thinks there's no viable path for
conservative policies or maybe he's just
a liberal himself and you know but
either way
when it comes to conservative fighting
he behaves like a child and apparently
he eats like one too speaking of
mastication before we get into the
mailbag
another video from a couple days ago
that I meant to get to fortunately we
have time today
Joe Biden
chewed on a child
and if you're if you're not
if you're not watching this
if you're not watching if you're just
hearing it I don't know how I can
describe it to you it's not I can't
overstate how weird this is
he leans in and it's not just a little
nuzzling with the child I actually think
that's kind of cute I know people say
that everything Joe Biden does is really
creepy and some of the things he does
but I don't know playing around making
goofy faces at a child I think that's
kind of cute but he leans in and just
starts
chewing on the child
and then he leans in and makes a goofy
face and then
he smells her hair again
he does the hair smell thing that's got
him in so much political trouble
and my takeaway from this is not as some
more
eccentric or energetic right-wingers
might say that he's a pedophile or
something like that my takeaway here is
the guy is in cognitive decline because
even if his mastication on the child and
the hair smelling is totally innocent
it's a huge political loser for him and
he is constantly criticized for it and
it's completely unnecessary and yet he
keeps doing it and why does he do it I
assume it's because he is obviously in
the throes of cognitive decline and the
thing that we haven't talked about too
much on the right we've all been making
fun of how Joe Biden you know is a
couple fries short of a Happy Meal you
know but Joe Biden is uh you know is not
the sharpest tool in the shed and seems
to be getting worse
if you've ever experienced cognitive
decline with a loved one a family member
someone like that you you know it's not
it's not just a gradual thing
starts out kind of slow and then it gets
dramatically worse
cognitive decline
at a certain age
really accelerates
and we've seen it really accelerate with
Biden and just think even though they
keep abiding broadly out of the public
site even though he doesn't give a lot
of speeches or rallies or campaign or
anything like that
this guy has a lot of pressure on him he
does have to be in public a considerable
amount
that pressure is on the one hand might
keep him a little bit with his wits
about him because at least his mind will
be stimulated but that's a lot of
pressure that's a lot of stress at that
age
Biden Biden could decline rapidly we
keep saying on the Republican side oh
it's a long way until the election right
that cuts both ways it's a long way
until the election if this is where we
are with Joe Biden now if we've seen
this kind of a decline from 2020 to 2023
is this guy going to be able to walk
around the campaign Trail in 2024 or is
Gavin Newsom going to be waiting in the
wings
I've got some fantastic news by the way
have you ever wondered what it would
have been like to take a stroll through
the capitol on
January 6th the worst day in the history
of this or any Republic
have you maybe wondered what it's like
to take a walk on the surface of the Sun
you're in luck because my guest on Mike
Land this week has first-hand experience
with at least one of those things though
he claims firsthand experience with both
this would be the first long-form
sit-down interview
that Jacob chansley the Q Anon Shaman
has given since being released from jail
you know the horn hat guy from January
6th check out this teaser you were in
solitary confinement for ten and a half
months ten and a half months that seems
like torture and I experienced a
miraculous things in solitary I'm
freaking out I'm in a Cell I'm freaking
out I'm like what the hell and I had a
Bible in my hand I said I need you to
speak with me so I closed my eyes I
opened the Bible I point to a random
verse and the verse was I am yours and
you are mine I have redeemed you and
called you by name oh Jacob
oh yeah
[Music]
what is a shaman what is a woman what
really happened on January 6th find out
in this hippie trippy interview out now
the big Tech approved version of this
episode is on YouTube
but if you want to catch the uncensored
version the full version you've got to
get that exclusively on Twitter at M
null show
and at Daily wire Plus
the mailbag is sponsored by Pure Talk go
to puretalk.com
fifty percent five zero percent off your
first month
take it away
hey Michael my name is intelio and as
you can probably tell by my accent I am
not an American but I am an Australian
and I listen to your show every single
day without fail I absolutely love it my
question is just in regards to
University and how best to navigate it I
am a Conservative Christian woman and
I'm currently studying to be an ancient
history High School teacher I'm
struggling at the moment because I'm
finding that my professors require me to
write woke papers and woke content that
I don't believe in generally speaking I
am an A plus student and get really good
grades but I'm struggling lately because
I don't know whether to stick by my
values and write papers I believe in or
to give in to my professors and write
work content that I don't believe in
just to get a good grade I know it
sounds like a cowardice question but I
genuinely am struggling so I'd love any
advice that you might have thank you so
much love the show
thank you so much that's one I'm so
pleased to hear we've got listeners down
in Australia I've heard this for some
years now makes me think we need an
Australian translation of reasons to
vote for Democrats too
it's a good question and
you're thinking that I'm going to give
you one of two answers either there's
the answer which I really disagree with
which is essentially oh just lie keep
your head down pretend to be a lib get
the degree and then later on you can
have integrity in your work which will
not happen
integrity and honesty it's something you
have to practice it's it's not something
that you're you're just suddenly going
to start doing later on in life when the
stakes are much higher than they are at
University when you've got a mortgage to
pay when you've got a job to keep so I'm
not going to tell you that likewise
though I'm not going to give you the
other answer which is you should just be
totally open and flamboyant at all times
about your views come what may because
then you possibly could flunk out and
then you don't get the degree and then
you don't get to do your job and then to
quote Mitch McConnell on the subject of
Elections the winners get to go make
laws and the losers go home I'm not
going to tell you that either I'm going
to give you an answer that a diplomat
friend once gave me
and he described it as the difference
between diplomacy and flattery
and here's here's the difference the
flatterer lies the flateral is dishonest
and will say really nice things about
the person that he wants to impress
regardless of whether or not they're
true simply to ingratiate himself to
that person and that's wrong and that's
a sin
the Diplomat however
will
say the good things that he can say
about the person that he is speaking
with
and he will say them truthfully and he
might omit other truthful things that
would be a little harsher but he will he
will highlight the good in order to have
a good relationship with this person and
then perhaps to have even more influence
later down the road
it's a subtle distinction but it's clear
enough
don't lie but you don't need to be
wearing the Maga hat or a horn hat or
something at the water cooler every day
or in your classroom
this is why and I say this often I
probably say it two or three times a
week we are called to be wise as
serpents and innocent as doves and this
I think that distinction might help you
your job in navigating these treacherous
Waters is to be a diplomat not a
flatterer
not a kamikaze
a diplomat and if you're ever really put
in a position where they say well hey
renounce what you believe lie
don't say don't tell the truth
well then the dye is cast and you you
have an obligation to the truth
but there's a lot of maneuvering there's
a lot of cleverness you're going to have
in the meantime next question
hi Michael it's Chuck Meister I recently
had a college friend an Indian guy shows
some interest in Catholicism and before
you ask unfortunately it wasn't Arun he
was raised Hindu and felt the surfaces
here were just a bit of a show he tried
going to some non-denominational church
and said I quote the services felt like
a cake made entirely of icing when he
was raised in India he went to Catholic
grade school and high school so he's
always had a reverence for the church
I've already told him to read the
introduction to the catechism in John 3
16. but what do you think would be the
most convincing argument for a Hindu
looking to convert to Catholicism aside
from watching the Michael Noel show love
the show thanks so good that's a good
way to do it you know I
love the Hindus
love Indians a disproportionate number
of my close friends have been Indian and
one of my very best friends is Hindu and
then of course one of the great
listeners to the show Arun is also an
Indian in the Hindu
uh and I would of course like all of
them to convert to Christianity
how do you convince a Hindu I love what
he says when he says I went to some
Modern lib kind of mega church liturgy
and it seemed like a case made entirely
of icing another way that this is
described is that the Catholic view is
first the fast then the feast
and the modern kind of eccentric view is
first the feast then The Hangover
so I would lean into that if that
appeals to him I would recommend that he
check out a traditional Latin Mass
because a traditional Latin Mass has
smells and bells I've visited India I
visited Varanasi which is probably the
spiritual capital of India it's the
oldest continuously inhabited city in
the world
all sorts of religious rituals that go
back many thousands of years temples to
Jupiter I mean really wild wild stuff
and so perhaps the ornate nature of the
traditional liturgy and its sheer weight
of History the fact that it's existed
for 2000 years and in its present
traditional liturgical form for very
least 500 years and really significantly
much longer than that uh that might
appeal to him
the fact that there is complexity to it
is important my priest in New York
wonderful man
pointed out that a lot of modern people
when they're looking for modern religion
they say I just wanted to be really
clear they'll say why do you people pray
to Saints or something I don't know why
do you engage in these ornate and
elaborate liturgies why do you partake
of the sacraments why do you do this
that and the other it's not clear why
isn't it just really simple and clear
and my priest points out shallows are
clear
shallows are clear
deep waters are murky they're darker
there's more to it you can't take it all
in at once shallow thinking is very
clear shallow religion is very very
clear
and and so Hinduism which is a pagan
type of religion is extraordinarily
complex it doesn't really have a
theology to it but it's got an
extraordinarily complex type of
mythology which can take you somewhere
it can it can
it can point you in broadly speaking
perhaps the right direction so then when
you apply the rigors of Theology and
accept complexity and ornateness and
the humility of not grasping it all at
once that that might appeal to him okay
next question hey Michael so seeing as
science is indeed fake
um claven had a creation scientist on
recently it reminded me of the fact that
while some of the current scientific
battles that were fighting like abortion
climate change vaccines and are all
worthy of fighting and winning I think
we're giving up one of the most
important scientific debates and we gave
it up a long time ago to the libs namely
that humans did not evolve from other
creatures we were created specifically
by God In His Image another piece that I
feel is pretty widely accepted by
conservatives is that the Earth is
billions and billions of years old
despite some pretty compelling fossil
evidence to the contrary as well as the
problem of death prior to the fall of
Man I think this is an area that is
really important that we seeded long ago
and the court cases in the mid 20th
century around education really helped
drive that home many of these problems
we face now in my opinion stem from us
giving up this debate so from your
perspective curious on your take of the
historical atom and the age of the Earth
if you think it could be 10 or 11 000
years old it's pretty base take if you
ask me really good question and I know
there are a lot of modern conservatives
who want to sidestep it because they
fear that if they at all question
whatever the prevailing Orthodoxy on
evolution is because it changes
considerably since the time of Darwin
seems to change year by year but if they
question whatever the fashionable view
is today then they'll be called Hicks or
Rubes or idiots or something like that
if they question how old the University
of the cosmos is the Earth is even
though again science changes that number
pretty regularly but if we question it
then you know we're a big bunch of hick
rube idiots so they don't want to engage
in that but it's a serious debate
and and so
how how must one think about it I
suppose I just don't think about it very
often because science is fake and
because virtually every claim ever made
by modern science after the Scientific
Revolution is false then or has been
proven false at some point I just don't
worry about it too much and I accept the
nice advances in technology uh with
caution because very often those
advances in technology have all sorts of
externalities that cause all sorts of
problems in the world so I approach even
even that even the very best products of
the Scientific Revolution I approach
them with some caution interpretation I
I reject the world view that has come
out of the Scientific Revolution which
is that all that really matters about
reality is fundamentally physical I just
that's not true that's obviously not
true
um so I reject that
and then in terms of the age of the
world or anything it just doesn't affect
my life in any way it doesn't affect
forget even my personal life it doesn't
affect my thinking and the way I think
about other things all that much
I consider Genesis to be the most
insightful account of the creation and
so if in some physical way the the
physical history of the world is somehow
uh different or I don't know
distinguished in some way from that
account I don't really care because the
story in just a handful of chapters that
I see in Genesis most clearly to me
accounts for uh how the world really
works the one thing I would insist upon
I would not insist upon the Earth being
I don't know 10 000 years old or
something I would not insist upon
this type of evolution or that type of
evolution or no type of evolution the
one thing I would insist upon though is
a real Adam and Eve I think I think
human beings must descend from a real
Adam and Eve from a common ancestor this
is called monogenism and papayas the
12th insisted upon this in Omani generis
we have to do that or else our
understanding even of human nature
falls apart and okay so let's say that
our understanding of human nature is
wrong well I don't know what vision of
human nature would replace it the the
libs who would replace it don't have
much of an answer to that and they don't
really have much evidence that we don't
descend from a common ancestor they
don't really have any evidence of at all
of that so that is the part where I
think one really must insist for one's
Faith okay next question
hello Mr Knowles it is your favorite
bass player once again slap my base
coming at you with a music question of
all things so recently I just joined a
church band playing bass of course and
my question to you is how do you feel
about contemporary music performing in
churches for example guitars and basses
as opposed to the traditional pipe organ
that would proclaim the hymns or
if they are using some sort of new age
hymns that you would find on something
like a worship together compilation that
you get from Time Life Magazine I'm
curious about what your thoughts are
thanks for your time once again I love
the bass I know you're an excellent
bassist
I don't think that stuff belongs in
church
I don't think that Brahms belongs at a
rock concert and I don't think that the
modern pop bubble gum music or even
worse the the highly percussive music
belongs in church because music is
really important as Plato points out it
bypasses the reason it speaks most
directly to our souls and it can shape
our souls this is why if you get out of
a car and you've been listening to rap
music and some kind of Gangsta hideous
rep your mind's going to be in a worse
place your your whole self is going to
be in a worse place and the same thing
is true in church this is why I'll go
even further I'm skeptical of uh
polyphony in church you know I'm more a
fan of monophony
meaning uh
plain chant rugorian chant I think is
much more conducive to worship the the
early Christians
throughout the Middle Ages
preferred Gregorian chant uh not because
they hadn't discovered Harmony
pre-christian worship music
pre-christian liturgical music was much
more ornate than the kind of music you
saw from the early church up through the
Middle Ages and in some traditional
parishes today
the Christians
stripped it down a little bit and and
brought it into that Unison chanting for
a reason because it focuses the mind and
it takes it actually takes personality
out of it when the when the gospel is
chanted rather than read that's not a
way to show off your singing skills if
you're a priest that's a way to take the
personality out of it so you don't have
some some ham actor yucking it up there
on the altar but you've got you've just
got the word of God coming to you in
this beautiful way that speaks directly
into your soul and so I would just be
careful of it especially with percussion
it can rile you up it Riles up the base
passions and it can take your mind and
soul off the worship of God as it ought
to be done properly and reverently all
right the rest of the show continues now
on that harsh note on that Footloose
note no rock music you know why the
Baptists refuse to drink
because they know that drinking can lead
to dancing that's right become a member
right now use code Knowles Canada Wally
has a check out for two months free on
all annual plans and go to
libre.hu and get your copy of miera to
us fats
we'll see at the member block
[Music]
thank you
foreign